President Trump is showing new
impatience with the Russia investigation
and reluctance to accept evidence that
Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince ordered the
murder of a Washington Post contributor
the president said in a weekend
interview that he's spent enough time
answering Special Counsel Robert
Miller's questions and he will not
interfere with decisions made by
Miller's new boss major Garrett is at
the White House major good morning good
morning before taking his post as Acting
Attorney General Matt Whitaker as we now
know and has been well established often
criticized Robert Muller Special Counsel
investigation for that and many other
reasons Democrats on Capitol Hill want
Whitaker to recuse himself President
Trump said an interview yesterday
Whitakers appointment is temporary but
for as long as he has that job he can do
what he wants it's gonna be up to him I
think he's very well aware politically
he's a very smart person he's gonna do
what's right
president Trump said he would not
interfere with acting Attorney General
met Whitaker if he moves to curtail
Special Counsel Robert Muller's Russia
investigation
I would not get involved Whitaker
oversees the Muller probe and faces
calls to recuse himself because of past
remarks like these suggesting ways to
hobble Muller that Attorney General
doesn't fire Bob Muller but he just
reduces the budget so low that his his
investigation grinds to it absolutely
almost something the president said he
knew nothing about before he named
Whitaker to replace former attorney
general Jeff Sessions those statements
that can they really can be viewed
either way the biggest flaw from my
point of view is that he was chosen for
the purpose of interfering with the
Muller investigation California Democrat
Adam Schiff called Whitaker's
appointment unconstitutional raceless
this is attack on the rule of law firing
back on twitter and misspelling shifts
name the president noted that like
Whitaker special counsel Muller is also
not Senate confirmed for his current
post your team is preparing written
answers to questions about my team I'm
preparing written answers like I'm the
one that does the answer mr. Trump also
insisted written answers to Muller came
from him not his lawyers he said it was
unlikely he would interview with Muller
or his team I think we've wasted enough
time on this witch-hunt
and the answers probably were finished
Republicans on Capitol Hill continue to
warn this White House and the president
not to interfere or end the Muller
investigation Lindsey Graham Republican
senator from South Carolina Nora said
doing so would be quote a disaster let
me also ask you major about Chris
Wallace's questions about the president
and the military specifically retired
Admiral William McRaven who has
criticized President Trump by saying
that his attacks on the media are the
greatest threat to our democracy why did
President Trump respond the way he did
well the president took that criticism
from the Craven and immediately tried to
contextualize and say well he's a
Hillary Clinton fan and Obama backer
suggesting that a partisan orientation
is more important to why McRaven said
calling the Free Press an enemy of the
American people is a great threat to
democracy and the president also said
wouldn't have been nice to get was Osama
bin Laden earlier well McRaven had no
control over the order but when the
order was given by President Obama he
carried it out one other thing Chris
Wallace asked the president about why
hasn't he seen American forces in Iraq
or Afghanistan as presidents typically
do president said Nora that trip is
being planned yeah there was an
important question to think about the
commander-in-chief has still not visited
our troops who are stationed in Iraq or
Afghanistan previous presidents usually
do that over Thanksgiving or near the
Christmas holidays to let them know that
they're still cared for maybe he's
planning a surprise and we don't know it
yeah we'll see and as Mike Morell former
acting director the CIA said it's
backing up what major said that the
CIA's job to go find bin Laden and then
McRaven yes went after execute and the
Navy SEALs and the Navy SEALs that's
right Thank You major